[موسيقى]
يعني اقصد ان كل اعضاء النظام السابق
والا اللي كانوا في النظام السابق
الليبيين وهذين لهم حقوق وحقوقنا وحقوقهم
متساويه ما فيش فرق خلاص ننسى الان امامنا
وطن امامنا ليبيا فبراير نظام سابق اي
مسميات اخرى لابد ان نحن نعمل معا
وبالنسبه للمصالحه هي اساسا واقعيين بدات
المصالحه هذه كيف بدات وتقولين كيف بدات
صحيح ما فيش معتمر كبير تقوده الامم
المتحده ولا الاتحاد الافريقي ولا المجلس
الرئيسي وقاعدين يخططوه لحد الان لكن
المصالحه مع النظام السابق بدات من حكومه
السراج حكومه السراج فيها وزراء كانوا من
نظام السابق الحاج محمد السياله والدكتور
طاهر الجيمي هذا مكانهم النظام السابق
ايضا الان نشوفوا حكومه دبيبه حكومه دبيبه
رئيسها من النظام السابق يعني يوم من
الايام كان مبعوث شخصي لمعمرك الدافي
لمدينه مصراته على اساس انه
يتخلوا على الثوره وتعرض حتى
للحبس في مدينه مصراته
[موسيقى]
ممكن اتوقع يعني في حال لو استلمتم
الحكومه بشكل مطلق في ليبيا انه يصير في
اي اجراء بخصوص المساجين المهمين الحقيقه
من النظام السابق الموجودين في السجون من
امثال عبد الله السنوسي وعبد الله منصور
وغيرهم
بالنسبه لي يعني بسبب الاسباب لا اريد ان
يبقى اي ليبي لاسباب سياسيه لان احنا
عانينا من فتره النظام السابق معمر في ناس
كثيرين سجنهم بسبب احداث سياسيه او موقف
سياسي لا نريد احد ان يبقى بسبب موقف
السياسي ان كان في النظام السابق او كان
في العهد الملكي
والمصالحه تتطلب ايضا ان احنا لابد ان
يكون فيه اعفاء عفو عام بما لا يتعارض مع
الحقوق اللي هي الحقوق الشخصيه فانا
بالنسبه ما عنديش مانع لكن على شرط انه هو
لا يتعارض مع الحقوق يعني مقفول حق الشخص
اذا كان بيقدم شكوى فيه لكن حاسبوه على
انه كان في النظام السابق خلاص انتهت
الفتره هذه توه الان بوليفيا ولابد ان
احنا
ونتركه هذا للقضاء الحقيقي القضاء اللي
بدون ضغط
[موسيقى]